good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday hope
everyone had an amazing refreshing
delightful and brilliant weekend i
really had an amazing refreshing
delightful and brilliant weekend i
really did it was so relaxing caught up
on my z's got some good sleep in despite
the big belly
watched a lot of great tv read a
horrible book so it was really all over
the place a little bit of everything and
i saw my friends so i really felt like i
did it all had a nice blend balance of
activities well you love a blended
moment you do i had an amazing weekend
with one major
snafu i wouldn't say snafu i would say
like
ruiner one big ruiner okay do you know
what it is no
on friday night i was out at a
restaurant and i saw cuba getting junior
oh yeah yeah so in this restaurant that
has like a bunch of different rooms like
i'm sitting in this one particular room
called the grill and he like pops his
head in and i'm sitting by like the
entrance and i guess he was looking for
someone so he pops his head in
and like looks around like fully makes
eye contact with me but you know i'm
just like one of millions so that he
doesn't even recognize you he's like
it's another butt to him yeah like i'm
not even uh
like a thought process and then i was
like i was getting really drunk and i
was like i think i'm gonna say something
obviously i didn't but like i did go to
the bathroom and then as i was like
making my way through the crowd i got
like stopped because like these people
were just like mobbing and i couldn't
get through and who am i standing
directly next to cuba getting junior wow
so it was a great weekend full of laughs
loves friends you guys actually have
like very similar tastes in restaurants
i see him
everywhere so i'm in the hamptons
recently that's crazy no i know it's
very jarring are you okay yeah no i'm
fine but it did like rattle me like for
a minute when i was in the restaurant
that's rattling yeah it was just like
very like a disassociative is that the
right word moment yeah and [ __ ] him so
damn
sorry other than that i had a really
nice weekend i'm so glad i too read a
book that i hated
i can't believe you hated it she read
one day in december which if you're a
reader and you like you know a snitch's
choice it's a classic it was so corny
and it was
hella long for a while where nothing
happened but it is pretty long but if
you like the book then it's you know not
long enough didn't love the characters
like i'm like why is like everyone
obsessed with this guy jack like he
sounds ugly like the way they keep
describing him like he's messy i'm like
who the [ __ ] wants to be with someone
messy it was just not my favorite book
but it did get me one book closer to my
goal of 20 it took my goal of 30 because
i'm at 26 now so i am almost done with
this book that i started and i did i
would have finished it if it were good
but you know i was avoiding it all
weekend wish you were here by jodi
picoult and it is so bad it's all about
covid like i thought
no no it's more about kobe than i could
have ever even dreamed like
first i was like okay it's about you
know she gets stuck on this island
because there's you know like the travel
bans and coven is in the background
which is like okay kind of interesting
whatever um then it turns it just like
completely turns i don't want to spoil
it but it's it couldn't be more about
coping it could not be more about
covalent sounds and i'm gonna finish it
because like i need to get to my
goodreads
and because i do want to finish it
before i make a judgment
but i'm at 70
and i would not recommend this to
someone that i love okay but you would
recommend it to someone that you
despised
yes got it okay i've got a few people i
got an email
um
well yes it was a great weekend like i
had a good balance like a saturday i was
drinking all day we went to the pier
17
rooftop where they have those like
cabins and it was just i'm sorry you
weren't there and i hate to like talk
about it because i know no i'm so glad
you guys went and had a good time it was
so nice it was just a great way to spend
the day like in new york it was gorgeous
out we played games we were drinking in
this little cabin it was just a great
saturday and i feel like if i were going
you wouldn't have felt as comfortable
bringing games because you would have
known no in our group chat where you
said i'm too tired i'm not coming
i then was like oh great let me bring
some games but then when i brought the
games becky from the redheads did let me
know she also despises games but she she
put her differences she totally won her
over like the the camaraderie and the
sportsmanship and the sheer joy of the
games was contagious okay i'm so happy
for you guys that's a great way to spend
the day it really was nice and then i
got to spend all sunday like cultivating
a vibe and relaxing so i think that's
called balance that is balance and you
do love to see it you do definitely love
to you do
do is here today and he's being like
extra cute and like really attached to
me so we have been alone since like
thursday me and theo because um
his father
flew south and it's really just
connected us in this like deep way and i
think that's kind of what you're feeling
like that energy yeah no he's just being
very emotionally supportive
you can always you cannot you can't
count on theo for a lot you can count on
him to be extremely emotionally
supportive yeah and you can count on
brood to be so handsome and charming so
delicious and gorgeous so lovely
everybody loves brew we have an amazing
show because of course we've got the
past five that we gotta talk about we've
got some good [ __ ] in there okay good
that's it's always a toss up so it's so
great you never know you never know
um we're gonna talk about the real
housewives of salt lake city at the end
of the tv recap and i heard you had some
other things you wanted to throw in the
tv recap yes here's what i watch i watch
sex lives of college girls did you love
it love good oh my god it was just like
this beautiful little nugget of a show
and it was so
spot-on in terms of capturing the
culture of college especially like small
liberal arts
school in the northeast which is where i
went so i i did feel very akin to it
and um and and the like awkwardness and
dynamics of freshman year or it was
palpable yeah it was really really good
so i mean we can talk about it more in
the tv recap and then i caught up on
yellowstone on the new season i had been
saving it for a rainy day
and when it rained it poured and i
watch the new season and it is so
[ __ ] good
it is the best show on television like i
gotta get into it it's just like
normally so
good
it's so oh my god it was and then the
new episode was on last night and so i
just rolled into the new episode and i
just i love it so much well you rolled
into the new episode thus missing the
season finale of succession i knew it
was the season actually you want to
blame someone i blame zach because i
knew you were going to say that because
we had like a date to watch it together
at a certain time and he just never
showed up well to be honest i watched
the whole episode not reeling it wasn't
realizing it was the finale because it
was episode nine and like most hp
episodes have ten episodes like it was
just
randomly nine but it was incredible did
something finally [ __ ] happen
something
huge thank you and something so
unexpected like you're thinking like
what like it's just it's not even
remotely what i was thinking was gonna
happen okay well i'm really excited to
watch something happen on the show where
nothing happens you just plug yours for
one second
uh
just put yours for one second i want to
say one thing but then we have to put in
spoilers in the in the thing and you
know i think people really appreciated
that on the sex in the city even though
all right fun spoilers we're about to
spoil sex and city again today and at
this point if you haven't avoided
spoilers you're out of control obviously
don't spend a lot of time on the
internet and you're not listening to
this podcast oh and you're not watching
sex the city because it's been out for
four days so yeah no but like it's
everywhere now so i'm sorry we're gonna
just agree to get into it without
further ado yeah i'm sorry i'll try i'm
going to watch succession today does
that work for you or like this just
takes away the fun no it's just like
everyone's talking about it today and
we're not because you couldn't do it i
didn't realize it was a season finale
neither did i but also the show was
really bad it doesn't deserve my like
live viewing it's still pretty good no
it's really really bad not every episode
for a show that should be spectacular it
has everything the storyline the
characters the scenery
the you know hbo budget it's not good
what i think about succession is like
yes not every episode is like a bang out
like amazing thing and some of the
characters are so unlikable that when
it's one of those kind of low-key
episodes they're like laying groundwork
for what comes next you're just left
with the characters and like i can't
even find someone even remotely
sympathetic like i think the person i
probably like best is roman and like
he's a freak you know yeah so you're not
left with much on the episodes where
there's not crazy high intense drama
yeah i guess but it shouldn't like it
doesn't always need to be such drama i'm
trying to think of like yellowstone is
super dramatic this season but it's
always like crazy but they also are
doing like a lot of more cowboy stuff
and like a lot of i don't know if it was
always like this like a lot of music and
like just scenes of ranching and i think
like just people love
ranch life ranch life
did you see the interview with the actor
who plays kendall roy that went like
completely viral where he like is
talking about how serious he takes it
and playing it like a comedy but also
like hamlet right but also like people
then thinking like literally he was in
kendall roy while he was doing this
interview because he's being so serious
yeah i haven't read it but it's a
written interview right i i don't know
yeah yeah not a video okay then i saw a
clip yeah i have to watch it because
people are like obsessing over this
interview like how
the guy what's his name who plays
kendall like is kendall
got it which makes sense because i don't
think anyone's that good of an actor
yeah
that makes sense
um okay so now without further ado
it is time for the fast life stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
bowling branch the gift everyone wants
is a better night's sleep and bowling
branch never disappoints with the
highest quality sheets blankets pillows
and throws plus their holiday packaging
makes your gift look and feel special
so we preach about bowling branch all
the time my throw blanket my pillowcases
my duvet cover my sheets
mostly everything on my bed is from
bowling branch and i've never looked
back as someone who gets very warm in
her sleep i find the material to be
extremely breathable they have a ton of
different designs available so many
different accessories too like throw
blankets and pillows
the signature hem sheets are the ones
that i have and that's our all-time best
seller they're beloved for many reasons
they get softer with every wash they're
buttery soft lightweight and made with
100 organic weave that feels incredible
at all seasons it comes in a wide range
of colors and sizes and they go from a
twin up to a california king treat
yourself and your loved ones to the new
standard embedding from bowlin branch
their gifts come wrapped and ready in a
special holiday packaging and if you
order by 12 19 you'll have guaranteed
delivery by christmas shop the holiday
semi-annual sale from
december 9th to december 15th and get 20
off at bowlingbranch.com that's b-o-l-l
and branch dot com seaside for details
exclusions may apply but their holiday
semi-annual sale goes on from december
9th till december 15th and you can get
20 off at bowlandbranch.com
wonderful our first story spoiler alert
but it's time that you found out we're
talking about sex of the city so peloton
responds to and just like that death
with a new ad
and just like that mr big is alive well
at least in a new ad for peloton the
fitness company released a commercial
featuring chris noth on sunday just days
after his beloved sexism city character
was pronounced dead in hbo max's revival
series
so the new commercial shows chris noth
and jess king who's a peloton instructor
chris knowlth
i mean it depends okay yeah where you're
from
yeah um and jess king who plays allegra
but she's a real peloton instructor
sitting across from each other on a
couch in front of a crackling fire he
says to new beginnings and then she says
should we take another ride life's too
short not to then they say and just like
that the world was reminded that regular
cycling stimulates and improves your
heart lungs and circulation reducing
your risk of cardiovascular diseases
cycling strengthens your heart muscles
lowers rest resting pulse and reduces
blood fat levels he's alive
so you know that was ryan reynolds voice
i just found that out while he reading
this i was shook by that i didn't really
understand like why i don't know either
and
he i also saw that he posted the
clip me too and so i was like oh that's
where maybe he's an investor that's what
i was thinking but then remember when
two or three years ago i guess was three
years ago when peloton had that cringy
christmas commercial
and then like ryan reynolds like
parodied it didn't for his gym company
oh yeah that was a weird time yeah
and so i'm like what is ryan reynolds
disconnect this he's about two for two
on on peloton commercials no there's
something going on between ryan reynolds
and peloton yeah okay but we need to
discuss this obviously genius marketing
well you know what soul cycle snapped
back first and put out like a
tweet like maybe mr big should have
gone to soulcycle yeah and so like that
was cute and funny and it got like a lot
of likes and it was very like widely
shared no i'm sure social media managers
across the world were quaking as to how
to make the most of this opportunity no
millennials with like social media with
marketing degrees like were
fully working this weekend yeah but no
one
got it better than peloton but this begs
the question like was this filmed in the
last four days or like has peloton been
in on this the whole time had this plan
and maybe like hbo was like hey listen
we're about to like be slanderous as
[ __ ]
if you want to get in front of it right
and so that was chris knows in the
he like looked kind of different i was
like is that someone pretending to be
chris noth because i'm like
his features just looked off and i
wasn't 100 sure by all accounts it's him
yeah you know i i believe that so
i definitely felt like
it felt like they filmed it in the last
four days but not only do they have to
produce edit
everything they also have to negotiate a
deal with chris noth for he obviously
got paid to be like in this peloton ad
so that takes months like i just i'm not
sure
i'm starting to feel like
it was pre-planned yes but didn't
peloton post something like on friday
they had a statement yes that was very
like backtracky
right so it seemed like they like
freaked out put something out and then
like had a few days and came up with
something better like it did feel like
it was all happening in real time i
don't know but like to execute these
contracts to get chris to the studio
right marshall get a ryan's voice so i
guess he could have sent in a voice note
but you know get a video person sound
like you know i mean i guess it was just
one shot and they literally like zoomed
out like but it's high quality these
things weirdly take a long time to do i
hope that we get clarity but if i had to
guess i would i would say that this was
filmed before thursday
i don't know
i don't know
i kind of don't think so
that would be crazy that would be crazy
it would be very unlikely but it did
feel all very thrown together like with
their initial like panicky statement
and now this like funny light-hearted
version yeah no i feel like with this
peloton is complete not that like it
even should really have
really if you watch tv real world
peloton's gonna kill me like you need to
stop watching tv right or you were just
not gonna get on the peloton to begin
with now you have an excuse totally but
i do think that with this like peloton i
hope the stock levels because they don't
do anything wrong yeah yeah and it
really it is good to work out
and exercise those cardiovascular
muscles but you know what's so funny
like out of
any brand like i feel like we're always
talking about the peloton stock here on
the show like it's always a topic of
conversation maybe because they're you
know a newer brand that's like has
relevance that is public and they're
also just like really part of like the
cultural like zeitgeist and and i i feel
like especially with covid like peloton
is a real indicator of where we're at
it's just like such a big part of
people's lives yeah and like it's a
bigger part when you're staying home
more so just like i do feel like it's
kind of a decent barometer for what's
going on in the world yeah no i agree
like the more we're talking about
peloton like the more we're staying
inside right the higher peloton stock is
the less we're going in right right down
with peloton no i love i miss my peloton
it's been you can't do it or you just
don't want it no i can but like why
would i have like a sloth on there
totally i might as well just be
listening to music and sitting no no
you're getting something done getting
your heart rate up no but like
when i did it i did it maybe like four
months pregnant i only did it once
during pregnancy and like it was just
pathetic and now i'm like
triple the size it's just i don't know
what i would accomplish other than a bit
of fun but just even like putting on a
sports bra is like not going to happen
yeah
and i don't even think i have one that
would comfortably fit i [ __ ] hate
sports bras can i just say i like i mean
they're a great tool but um i would have
to buy if that like it would just be a
whole thing yeah also if you're
listening to this as a podcast please
know you are not getting pulled over
there's an incredibly loud annoying
siren behind us but you're good i've
heard louder we're going to continue on
i've heard louder i just want to know
you don't have to look in your rearview
mirror no one's coming behind you yeah
or maybe i mean
yes you're here have you broken a law
recently maybe you should pause make
sure that there's not another siren for
maybe for you
are you ready for our next story sure
the golden globe nominations are here
and we have some people what'd you say
the golden globe this
oh i'm rolling my eyes i [ __ ] hate
like
these types of award shows you know oh
more than any i hate the shows but i do
find interest in the nominations yeah
and also everyone else hates the shows
because
golden globes will no longer be streamed
on nbc they will no longer be lively
broadcasted i don't know if they're
going to be televised at all i think
that's for the best because you know
what we really don't care
yeah no we they we said we didn't care
and they now and they listen and yeah
they know but they're still gonna you
know go ahead with i guess having the
show
so this year's event won't be televised
the 2022 golden globes are pushing
forward on monday morning the hollywood
farm press association announced the
movies and television shows nominated
for the 79th annual golden globes awards
snoop dogg helped announce the nominees
so even though
they
will
not be aired on nbc it's unclear if and
where they would be aired maybe they're
still working that out we have our
nominations are you ready
yeah i just want to say that i do feel
like this is like the beginning of the
end for the golden globes correct like i
mean god will yeah from our mouth to god
now like and i just feel this way about
award shows i do think that between the
grammys i mean the emmys are just like
grammys are great no between grammys
oscar's golden globes like i would think
the golden globes would go first yeah
and then i do i don't see the oscars or
grammys going anywhere but see the emmys
are unique in the sense that like they
cover exclusively tv so like they really
are kind of like a necessary thing
whereas like golden globes like
tv and like get out of here no they're
they're extremely redundant and it's
like a seated dinner and it just always
comes off as so
tone deaf yeah
so
it's interesting to hear what they think
are the top shows so let's get into it
best tv series musical or comedy
the great
hacks only murders in the building
reservation dogs ted lasso only murders
in the building should win yeah honestly
those are all good shows except and i
um a lot of people ask me if i watch the
great because it's about catherine the
great and it starts l fanning and it's
like a comedy about like uh you know
catherine the great in russia and i
actually watched a ton of episodes and i
really didn't like it and that was
surprising for me and i think other
people would be surprised by that
because you would think that that's a
show that you would like and i found it
to be so goddamn annoying and stupid and
like i now i i do want to watch a show
by catherine the great just not that one
got it
best motion picture musical or comedy
serrano don't look up licorice pizza
tick tick boom west side story
couldn't care less i haven't seen any of
those yet
but you never know don't look up is that
new one it's like a satire it's on
netflix with like everyone's in it yeah
jonah hill jennifer lawrence leonardo
dicaprio i will be watching that tick
tick boom i heard was good andrew
garfield netflix yes and west side story
which we have a story about west side
story so we'll talk about okay because i
also want to talk about west side story
okay we're going to we actually will be
talking about of it all like we will be
talking okay best actor in a tv series
drama brian cox succession that's logan
oh
lee jong-jae squid game okay billy
porter pose okay jeremy strong
succession that's kendall
omar sai lupin
i haven't heard of that show but um
great
yeah best supporting actress in a motion
picture
catriona balf belfast ariana debose west
side story kirsten dunst the power of
the dog anu j ellis king richard ruth
nega passing
unfamiliar with all of those movies yeah
best actress in a mini series or
television film jessica chastain scenes
from a marriage cynthia oh i do want to
see that
it's out it's yeah right cynthia rivo
genius aretha elizabeth olsen one
division i always mean to watch me too
and then whenever i'm scraping the
bottle barrel it doesn't even cross my
mind no and like we're just too late
yeah margaret quality made
kate winslet maravee's town
best actor in a mini-series or
television film paul bettany one
division oscar isaac scenes from a
marriage michael keaton dopesick ewan
mcgregor halston tahar rahim the serpent
the only one i've seen is halston and i
didn't think it was golden globe
award-worthy whatever that means
best action actor in a motion picture
musical or comedy leonardo dicaprio
don't look up peter dinklage serrano
andrew garfield tictic boom cooper
hoffman licorice pizza anthony ramos in
the heights so ansel elgort didn't get
nominated
no he did not best i don't know if he
deserves we haven't seen it i'm just
remarking best tv series drama lupin the
morning show pose squid game succession
did rachel zegler get
lead actress in a
comedy musical uh nope
nope she did not so rachel zegler is
playing his plays maria she did she did
they have it out of order yes oh good
for her
so she if you guys don't know she um
plays rachel in the new stephen
spielberg west side story which is why i
think there's all this kind of like
hoopla for it obviously because it's
steven spielberg but also because she's
like this unknown she went viral in this
like gorgeous rendition of her singing
shallow by lady gaga and literally she
got the part from that this is like her
first major role and i'm actually
looking forward to seeing her in it like
i'm going to watch it definitely at some
point yeah she's nominated in best
actress in a motion picture musical or
comedy along with marion cotillard
and who's in the net alana heym licorice
pizza i'm assuming that's one of the
hame girlies what's licorice pizza i've
never heard of it no one why is a hame
sister it sounds delicious it sounds
vile actually jennifer lawrence don't
look up emma stone cruella
well deserved well deserved and then
rachel zegler oh rachel zegler must be
so excited like she literally was like
the video of her went viral she was in a
high school auditorium she's like super
young
yeah this must have just been like the
most thrilling last year
yeah very exciting honestly there are so
many [ __ ] categories i really can't
continue to go through them especially
when we've seen like none of the films
they're referring to yeah but i would
say the biggest most important category
typically is best motion picture drama
those are like the ones you can expect
to see at the oscars and this is what we
have
belfast belfast coda
dune king richard the power of the dog i
heard dune was literally one of the
worst movies ever made yeah i didn't
hear a good thing zach watched it
like i just
haven't like i've been saving we have
been saving all these like
critically acclaimed movies to watch
while we're on vacation at the end of
the month and so i really can't offer
very much insight because i will only
have seen them come the new year i'll be
full of insight but three of those i
hadn't heard of which
coda and the power of the dog me there
so i mean that's you know enlightening
extremely enlightening yeah
well congratulations to all the nominees
good luck uh getting your award at a
show and nobody's watching yeah i wonder
if they still do the red carpet and
stuff
yeah i'm sure we'll get pictures and all
but not like live for me
probably not if it's like if the show's
not worthy of a broadcast but i really i
feel like this show might wind up being
broadcasted on like
goldenglobes.com paramount plus no
they're yeah first of all there's
literally no reason
so let's say whatever they lost their
licensing deal with nbc like it ran out
let's say that's the case there's
literally endless possibilities like a
million streaming services would love
the exclusive you could stream it for
free on your website you could have a
sponsor like what's going on with the
golden globes yeah maybe they just
haven't figured it out yet but i think
it will be available to stream something
you do i do okay we'll see yeah
next up a little more movie news west
side story falls flat at the box office
with a disappointing 10 million dollar
debut oh yeah they were expecting a
weekend in the weekend they were
expecting um like a hundred million
dollars and it came in at 10 they spent
100 million dollars on the movie and
audiences didn't open their wallets to
see the infamous rivalry between the
sharks and the jets play out on the big
screen west side story steven
spielberg's remake of the classic
musical fell flat in its box office
debut collecting a paltry 10.5 million
dollars from 2820 theaters despite its
first place finish the film's inaugural
ticket sales are cause for concern
because disney and 20th century studios
spent 100 million dollars to revive the
shakespearean love story for modern
times and stand to lose millions unless
west side story endures at the box
office through the holidays and oscar
season okay but like our movie ticket
figures back up postcodes like been up
there have been some big movies okay
that really it was possible it's
possible i think that
people thought that this would be one of
those movies because it's you know
steven spielberg it's a musical it's the
holidays yeah and even though you know
there's more weeks to be counted this is
a really
sad debut it is but i'm not surprised at
all because i really did not feel like
lots of promotion was put into
the like we
i know because i'm like such a a
pop culture tick tock freak but like the
story of rachel zegler like should have
been hella public i just feel like
it was like actually the movie had a
great story behind it about rachel and i
feel like there was like nothing really
done with that people don't really i
think know the whole rachel zegler story
i think the promo was bad and i think a
lot of it had to do with ansel elgort
like i think i don't know whether he
this movie was filmed before he was
accused of rape or they consciously cast
him in it after he was accused but they
like refused to promote the fact that he
was in it so like how can you promote a
movie without the main character
yes oh wow i saw him so i saw some
commercials for him and i thought that
it did look really good i think that the
um they flashed his face like once like
they're not proud of the fact that they
cast him so why didn't you i mean what
if it was already filmed right that's
but
was it i don't know i don't feel like
we've been talking about this for so
long but also
trying to figure out when the ansel
elgort stuff happened it was i think it
was like june 2020. it was like a while
ago yeah or july 2020
yeah so i can imagine maybe people just
didn't want to open up their pockets for
ansel elgort you think i just think that
i i actually don't know what to think
and i think that this is where hollywood
is too and also because like yes the
story of rachel zegler is beautiful you
know west side story is a classic tale
it's a holiday musical it's a big budget
production but it's also steven
spielberg and usually he puts asses in
seats right and so i think that's what
people are really having a hard time
wrapping their head around do you think
steven spielberg is like quaking this
morning i don't think he is thinking
he's lost his i think he already got
paid yeah for sure no actually and you
get a piece of
actually most like big actors and i
don't know about directors like you get
a huge chunk of whatever the movie
better the movie does like the better
for you but like okay so it so it's not
doing well like big whoop also i'm sure
that everyone there is just blaming
kobid and not really looking inwards and
saying why aren't we reaching people why
don't people want to come see us well
why i don't know i don't know either
well that's a problem they have to
figure out not us yeah because even
though like movies are down there have
been some good numbers recently and
things have been you know up and you
would have thought that something like
this would have brought people out well
i just want to say i definitely think it
has something to do with the bizarre
promotion of this film
having to do with ansel elgort that's
what i want to say okay that's like i
don't remember seeing a big commercial
i don't remember like if if this if this
wasn't the case with ansel algorithm i
feel like we've gotten like really we
would have gotten like really cute
pictures of like maybe him and rachel
zegler and everyone's like oh yeah like
we got nothing yeah
yeah i only found out that rachel zegler
was playing maria like a week ago
yeah but also she i mean for people who
aren't like well-versed in the you know
tick-tock viral videos she's an unknown
actress so they're like the only name
that they have to lead with is answers
and they couldn't they're not using it
so it's just like west side story with
steven spielberg yes and it's like every
part no and you know what i want to say
something hella hella controversial
is westside story a story that needs to
be retold many times and like in
different iterations i can't lie i've
seen it like once a million years ago
i'm not entirely sure what it's even
about
i've never seen it i don't think but
it's one of those movies that they
always redo
yeah but it reminds me of that you know
bring it on
um iteration the sharks versus the jets
100
and maybe this weekend spend your time
watching that such a good if you want a
modern retelling of west side story in
an impeccable way
i would watch i think it's bringing on
all or nothing too no no two is hayden
panettiere and solange knowles so that's
not even two two is um
but all or nothing is hayden penned here
wait hold on okay and that's bring it on
sharks first jets this is like four or
five
it's so twisted
in it to win it yes
you guys
that's the one i have to say i think the
hayden panettiere solange knowles one
like might be better than the original
no it's so [ __ ] good there's so many
good ones
bring it on again is number two and
you've seen it but it's not incredibly
memorable i don't think i actually have
seen it um
if i showed you if i
yeah like it's about a sorority
and
i've never seen that no you would you
have i know that you have because i've
seen everything you've seen but i'm just
telling you i haven't seen it i mean you
fell asleep but like you know what i'm
telling you that was a bad picture i've
never been in the presence of that film
no no i know that you have okay what's
the premise of the movie like they're in
they're college cheerleaders
okay competing i'm telling you i've
never seen it okay fine
um
anyways bring it on in a twin it like
stealing spielberg maybe you should
watch it maybe you should revive that
stephen
um
so yeah i am surprised by this but like
not really it's just been like a weird
movie that seems like cursed do you want
to see it like when you saw the promos
and stuff were you like oh i'm itching
to see that kind of like that
yeah yeah i'd like to see it as well
yeah hopefully i'll be streaming
somewhere soon yeah it's something i
feel like that's also like people just
want to watch from home i know it's like
i do love going to the movies i can't
remember the last time i've been
yeah it's one of my favorite activities
i never go yeah maybe it's because my
particular movie theater is just like
sad like no one's there i'm like always
the only one in the theater and it's
like boring
and like they don't even have a working
soda machine they have a bottle of soda
which is just unacceptable i do prefer a
bottle so
it's just like low budget because like
they haven't been open in six years so
it's like it's there's tumbleweeds
across the floor i'm like what is going
on yeah well if any of you have watched
it or saw it let us know what you
thought yeah and let us know why you
think it didn't do well at the box
office yes
um
but you know what is doing well at the
box office my skin thanks to urology
it's true curology customizes a
prescription formula with three active
ingredients picked for you to help
tackle your skin care needs whether
that's trying to take control of acne
fine lines dark spots breakouts clogged
pores you start curology by answering
online about your questions and if it's
a good fit then curology will match you
with a licensed dermatology provider who
will get to know your skin and subject
your consultation you get a customized
prescription cream to be sent straight
to your door
to address the acne fine lines dark
spots and more so again your skin is
more personal than comedy and there's
really no reason why we should all be
using the same products we all have
completely different skin we all have
completely different problems we have
different textures psychology is making
dermatology
personal and it's fabulous we've been
i've been on i'm thinking about like my
second delivery of curology the
consultation the questionnaire is
actually very very in-depth ask you a
lot of questions you upload pictures of
your face it's super in-depth and it
feels like they're really getting to
know your skin you can start your
chrology journey just like we did with a
free 30-day trial at curology.com
toast if prescribed just pay five
dollars for shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com slash toast to
unlock your free 30-day trial cancel
anytime
that's curology.com toast great our next
story some exciting legal news kim
kardashian passes the baby bar exam
she's one step closer to becoming an
attorney this morning kim announced that
she omf ggg i passed the baby bar exam
kim had previously failed the exam three
times but had coveted during one of
those attempts and now she has passed
and is on her way to becoming an
attorney i'm so proud of her
honestly and i hate to like even admit
that you know i was a doubter
non-believer but i was starting to think
that it just wasn't going to happen i
know because i remember reading
somewhere like some lie that said this
particular route she's taking you're
only allowed to try to take the baby bar
twice like if you don't pass it either
time like you're out well that was
clearly a lie that was clearly a lie so
she passed on the fourth time we love a
queen who doesn't give up who perseveres
beyond challenges which is like really
so admirable but you know what like and
i think kim probably feels this way too
like she's been so public about this
whole journey and like in order to get
there she has to pass this test and
there was no way this [ __ ] was not
passing this test like yeah the world
was watching people made so much fun of
kim like oh you can just buy your way
into being a lawyer she took the harder
route and she's doing it and i think she
was not gonna give up until she did it
she was not gonna let like everyone who
doubted her be right right but i think
also ever since you know like the first
time that she failed when we were all
you know so excited and then the second
time she did have clothed i think you
know these last two times like she's
really been working in silence and she
was like you know what i'll share good
news when i have it but like and i think
that's the best way to go about things
because it puts even more pressure on an
extremely pressure filled situation but
you know what there's all these things
happening with the kardashians that i'm
like actually really looking forward to
the hulu show but they had said they
promised i heard them say in an
interview like this time we're gonna
have much faster turnaround times so
when there's something going on in the
public eye it's not going to be a year
before we're able to address it but like
you know [ __ ] has gone on in the last
six months and like there's still no
[ __ ] show but they're technically
filming
yeah i i heard somewhere like chloe say
early 2022 we can expect okay so but
then we're to be talking about like kim
and p because i know they've been
filming like the kim's the pete stuff
and that's going to be like six months
more like six months is i mean it's
better than what it what it's if love
island can do it hulu can do it yeah i
think they like having a little buffer
either yeah because it makes it less
of a big deal yeah and by then we're
also we're all like kind of checked out
and on to the next thing and it's like
oh we cared so much about that then it
wasn't a big deal like we're over it
yeah so anyways i'm excited to watch
this
journey for kim i'm really
happy and proud of her and like that's
really [ __ ] hard so role models role
model role model and speaking of role
models our fifth and final story
times 2021 person of the year
is
dr theodore faceman
and to celebrate we've prepared a song
it's the final story
[Music]
[Music]
yes it's elon musk isn't it no it's
really dr theodor for chemin thanks to
his major contributions to the medical
field this year dr theodore for chapman
has been named as times 20 21 person of
the year we couldn't be prouder everyone
he sleeps his way to the top
and it's he's just an example to us all
to us all but
the runner-up was
elon musk the world's richest person in
tesla ceo has been chosen as times 2021
person of the year runner-up the
publication announced on monday december
13th
so this is a big deal
elon
i mean it is there are only like so many
people in the running for like times
person of the year i would say it's
probably like one of like 15 people you
know because you think of like
businessmen politicians activists like
there's not that many like who are all
the way up there
so elon was definitely if you had asked
me like who would have he was definitely
in the circle of people but i still am
very shocked by this yeah i'm shocked
that they're giving him like the credit
like that people hate him people do hate
him like haters gonna hate yeah but i i
mean he's my person of the year he's my
person every year can i tell you not to
be mean like i'm not loving the photo
they chose i don't really feel like it
does him justice i i think he's cuter
than that i agree and it's like
extremely serious and he's like kind of
goofy no and it has this like really
unflattering spotlight on him that's
like showing all his fine lines and
wrinkles like it's just rude yeah no
like he needs curology no he needs curly
and he just needs like airbrush like
everyone else like yeah what's with this
really like
it's harsh suddenly they're like
aeropostale or like one of those brands
like you know we don't airbrush
yeah no i agree it's definitely harsh
but i don't think elon cares i mean he's
probably not even seen the picture he's
you know he sat down for an interview
which i'm excited to read and i think
he's probably you know i don't think he
gets
too in the weeds about stuff like this
but i'm sure it's nice to be recognized
yeah
i mean like i know he's this
first like this controversial figure
because he's the richest man alive but
when you really think about what he's
contributed to society especially
through tesla and then all the space
stuff it's very impressive like you have
to you have to recognize that you do no
he's out here being a genius go elon go
elon it's your birthday go elon he's
albert einstein of our generation and i
would hope that albert einstein would be
on the cover of time i completely agree
that's how i feel about that i
completely agree so
anyways speaking of teslas um and this
will be a nice pivot into our tv recap
um
when
jenny i knew i knew exactly we were
gonna say
carlin when carlin pull like rolled out
of the tesla lamborghini like the jars
open i was just like this is all my
favorite things no i literally knew
exactly what you were gonna say okay but
let's launch into the tv recap which is
brought to you by bite toothpaste do you
know that over one billion plastic
toothpaste tubes are thrown out every
year ending up in landfills and oceans
that's 50 empire state buildings worth
of plastic every single year and bite is
reinventing personal care by making
products that are good for you and the
planet their hero product at bite is the
dry toothpaste tablets that come in a
reusable glass jar and the refills come
in home compostable pouches so you just
drop one in your mouth bite down and
start brushing your teeth it'll foam up
just like regular toothpaste but with no
plastic tube and no messy paste it's
really actually very premium experience
i know you think like i've been brushing
my teeth this one way my whole life how
will i change it's actually very easy
and if you travel a lot for work or
otherwise it's actually really um much
easier to use when you're just hopping
around and it's actually a really
fabulous product that you never
like think about but really makes a huge
difference on the environment they're
made with clean ingredients no harsh
chemicals sulfates or artificial dyes or
flavors their sustainability and clean
ingredients are at the center of
everything they do they are certified
carbon neutral cruelty free vegan and
palm oil free all their packaging and
shipping materials are refillable
recyclable or home compostable so if you
care about the environment and like to
have delicious breath check out bite
toothpaste they're offering our
listeners 20 off your first subscription
order go to trybite.com
toast or use code toast at checkout to
claim the deal that's
t-r-y-b-i-t-e dot com toast or use code
toast at tri bite dot com for 20 off
your first subscription order elon would
love bite breaking news miss india has
won miss universe oh amazing
congratulations um okay
salt lake city was like such a messy
episode because these women just can't
[ __ ] stay on track for one goddamn
thing like suddenly we're all just so
invested in mary and okay maybe that's a
conversation worth having but like can
we just hear from jen first she just got
out of jail yeah it was i don't know if
it was just because i spent the whole
day watching yellowstone and then it was
just like such a stark difference it's
possible like it was just all over the
place and i felt that way last week too
where it's like i don't know where my
loyalties lie like so many people like
half the time make sense half the time
make no sense and i just there's no one
that i can really
ride with and when it comes i think the
person i can ride with is meredith yes
but she's pretty disengaged from the
situation but when it comes to the gen
situation i'm feeling so conflicted
about all of these like legal things
airing out on reality television and i
just want to talk about it because
when so i watched a little bit of watch
what happens live just until the first
time
jeff lewis and lisa
and it's like if this were your actual
friend so i guess if you're one of the
women but it's hard to tell like to what
degree they're actually friends or
co-workers right so that's weird but in
general like if this were your friend
and they were going through something
like this like
what do you what is the moral thing to
do is it to stand by them or is it too
not i mean because really you are
innocent until proven guilty but it's
like i'm not i don't know jen so it's
i'm not in that position but as a viewer
it's like i don't know what i expect
these women to do and then jeff lewis
was talking about how when todd chrisley
was going through some legal drama okay
which i don't know what the drama was
okay either but he said oh they had some
tax stuff okay
so which is so different he said when
todd chrisley like was going through it
like jeffrey shout and todd was like you
know what you're actually one of two
people who have reached out to me like
all of his celebrity friends turn his
back on him and it turned out that
chrisley was proven innocent and like
that wasn't you know he made the right
move in reaching out but like
what if he was guilty did then should
you have not reached out like you how do
you preempt these things i don't know
you just need to really gauge it based
on like how well you know the person
like if if this was my friend let's say
like one of someone i really had a
friendship with and they said i didn't
do this like i would of course believe
them yeah i don't think jen has given a
single woman in this group the right the
the
reason to believe her yeah she's been
manipulative to them about like dumb
[ __ ] before this she's been mean to them
she's spread lies about them like so why
would they have any
cause to believe you now when the fbi is
at your door yeah i don't know i'm just
like
and i don't like it's just too much too
much for for just casual sunday night
viewing on bravo yes but you know what
it really did make me think like
i had a lot of problems with how erica
addressed everything but
she [ __ ] addressed it like this
delusional conversation she's having
with sharif like i didn't do it like
what like
you have absolutely no idea in the
entire world why a swat team showed up
at your house like i just find that very
hard to believe so like this la la land
like
oh what i saw my business partner stuart
and now pretending like she don't even
know stuart right um like this whole
fairy tale delusional story she's
telling it's actually making me
extremely grateful for the directness we
had from erica honestly right and also
we know in present day that stuart like
has pled guilty and that he is like
working giving them everything
so there there was nefarious business
transactions going on obviously and
she's literally just trying to dump this
whole thing on stuart
yeah well she's just trying to distance
herself from him and it's like wait what
we just watched you put a banana in his
mouth yeah like so i'm just frustrated
with that because
these like if the women in beverly hills
didn't do it these women are certainly
not going to be able to
no instead they're focusing their eyes
on mary like because jen has been proven
to potentially allegedly be a fraud
let's look at mary yeah and don't get me
wrong i definitely think there's
something worth like talking about like
i could see mary's church being in a
documentary on amazon in a few years
like there's something there for sure
yeah but we just take things one step at
a time there's no need to rush yeah i
agree it's it's a lot and it's a lot to
keep up with and
and i feel like i can't get behind
anyone you're right like with heather
i'm like you're the biggest loser i've
ever met in my life like oh jen is now
being accused of heinous crimes so
she'll she'll finally have time for you
and like you're the first person to show
up at her door like get a life like
she's heather's just taking l after l
this season i agree and then lisa like i
really do want to get behind because i
actually agree with her like she's the
only one who's being honest like she's
talking to her husband like what do i do
my friend just got like how do i be a
good friend while also being a good
person she's having a normal reaction
but this very stuff like she's so
[ __ ] delusional like that what
heather and whitney are saying she did
she 100 did she brought ham around she
dropped these crumbs she let other
people pick it up and then she flipped
on them also whitney like going and
calling cameron and thinking that she is
like doing something stealth of the
century it's like you literally just
fell even further than she could have
ever dreamed you did exactly what lisa
wanted you to do no no but i don't think
lisa ever dreamed that she would call
cameron i mean that's a best case
scenario take this all up as her own
know the exact same amount of
information as lisa and lisa doesn't
have to like continue to put it out
there like i know she thinks she was
doing something but i think she was
actually doing exactly what lisa could
only have dreamed of no she thought she
was like taking her power back and she
was giving every ounce of it up like it
was the worst call ever no i agree and
now she's in the same position as lisa
like and there's and she just keeps
thinking she's like oh and like i do
think lisa like there is a manipulative
thing happening where she wants to talk
about it she doesn't want to be the one
to bring it up we see it all the [ __ ]
time shannon
and
she's being called out on it but like
whitney is like think she's doing
something and she's not yeah and i'm
having a really hard time like
writing for whitney in other aspects
when what we saw last night let's talk
about iris symbol let's talk about iris
and bow wild rose a million dollar line
of credit 250 000 of their savings 20
000 for a party at your house with one
photographer twenty thousand dollars for
a photo shoot where there's no product
and no updated branding and oh as jenny
said you know a white wall and white
flowers
i it was making me very anxious like i
think we should shut this whole
operation down
no but it's like it's too late and also
that is so much money to put into a
business like i think at this point i
would say they've at least put in say
half a million of their own dollars like
into whitney's
skin care is that what it is it's a
skincare line um
and that's just too much
too much start your own business but
like in this day and age with like
shopify and all these platforms like you
really don't need to spend more than
like 30 thousand dollars to launch a
skincare brand no but like start small
like what did you spend all that money i
mean now seeing that she does a twenty
thousand dollar photo shoot right you
know oh she did 30 photo shoots she's
being taken for a ride she should start
small make sure that there's proof of
concept that people even want her new
skincare like you've been a housewife
for one season i
it's it's not a guarantee no and like
this is what andy talked about in one of
his books like the curse of housewives
is when you think that like your whole
life is gonna change forever and like
you have all this financial stability
and you make such bad financial
decisions and it's even worse when your
husband gets involved so i really hope
her husband just like keeps her on track
because she admitted like she's not good
with money and when literally someone
asked how much it cost for her to put on
that event at her house with a bunch of
influencers who just wanted to be on tv
like they she did not have to pay any of
those models her brand ambassadors she
had some champagne some fruit and one
woman with a camera how that's twenty
thousand dollars is beyond me she could
have done that party for fifteen hundred
dollars yeah so i'm really concerned and
it just doesn't have to be this way a
million dollar line of credit i'm not
saying like she shouldn't start a
business but like the you you have to
start smaller you know
every anyone should start a business
that they want without ruining the
financial standings of their families
and without a hundred percent of your
savings you know yeah sure dip into
savings that's that's what they're there
for
but not all of it no there's no very
frustrating i'm really like it was
it was upsetting yeah especially because
i can't really imagine how you spend 500
grand on the launch of a skin care line
that has no products like no but i'm
assuming 500 000
for the products from from the beginning
oh really yeah yeah for like bottles and
and and laughs how much are you [ __ ]
ordering in fact no but that's what i'm
saying like she should have been
ordering far less you know kylie started
with ten thousand lip kits right which
like for kylie was a small amount right
but
i i imagine like to start a a brand like
you do need capital it's not like a uh
a brand a business with no overhead so
i'm assuming she bought bottles she did
lab testing she has products she has
employees this and that's frightening
but the photo shoot
would say otherwise right there are no
products there's a rebrand photo shoot
with the old branding make it make sense
i know it's literally it's hurting me it
was painful and like i really
appreciated jenny for calling it out but
you know what the thing is about jenny
she has some of the worst takes of all
time like as it pertains to the ladies
drama and like she does have a few
things going for her
but she also has a lot of working
against her because everything that
comes out of her mouth i completely
disagree with i completely agree with
you
she's just not cutting it no she's like
she's she does have this vietnamese
party next week that i think becomes a
breeding ground for a lot of stuff and
she seems like she starts yelling and
like she needs to step her [ __ ] up and
that's from
sex and city she's just never [ __ ] up
um
because it's really not cutting it like
she can only she can only ride the
coattails of carlin for so long
i need 10 minutes dedicated to carlin at
the end of this episode but um
i saw that she gets up and starts
screaming but like i'm just praying for
her that she's screaming in the right
direction yeah she's always
like she's screaming about like you know
someone doing something irrelevant to
the situation next week she's going to
bring up like what happened between her
and mary a tubing a month ago yeah no
next week looks really chaotic and like
not in a good way you know yeah because
they're all at dinner and like i think
they they blow up was about marrying not
even about jen
yeah and they're all like turning on
each other like lisa and meredith right
what they literally said is the opposite
of what they were going to do when they
got to be able they had this like big
plan and i was all on board and nobody
has followed the plan it's so crazy and
chaotic and we need to talk about carlin
because she saved the episode with her
sophisticated taste buds
this i mean all of jenny's kids are so
cute and but like carlin is just
everything of the sort can i say i don't
really have like a personal connection
to carlin like you do so i'll just let
you take the floor
but i was looking on twitter and like a
lot of people feel this way about carlin
that she is like the unsung hero of this
season which is she's just like so she's
so mature which you know jenny said
she's a 45 year old woman she is the
sophisticated taste but thing is like
hysterical no and you know you sent me a
tweet that really summed it up perfectly
like carlin is exactly who brooks marx
thought he was last season thought he
was going to be yeah but no and life had
other plans yeah man plans god bless god
laughs and it's just always a joy to see
jenny's wonderful children like i'm glad
they're using her as the asset that she
is no like and for that reason i hope
she stays on this jenny might might get
a second season and it's all because of
carlin no but it's really just nice to
see like well-behaved respectful
children yeah real housewives because
typically i would say 80 percent of the
time like they really are but maybe
because they're also mostly like
teenagers and they're just in this
rebellious phase and they're spoiled and
it's right and it's just like it's hard
to watch but it's such a joy to watch
like these kids who are so into science
and food and just like living really
cute yeah i agree it's really just sweet
do you want a spin-off cruising with
carlin i would love a spin-off like
where maybe like carlin goes out like
science experiments like bill nye like
carla's a science guy yeah or like i
need to come up with a better like
carlin's corner where like she teaches
you something new every day right but
also she has this like sophisticated
palette like maybe we get her on the
road with guy fieri divers dragons and
dives with carlin that's not a bad idea
dynamic duo free idea
so cute
so all in all it was like a chaotic
episode but it's good like things are
moving and it's better than you know
some of the franchises we've had
recently we're like nothing moved agreed
um and then he was considering this is
like the biggest drama to hit housewives
um in a long time a lot of them they're
dropping the ball it's not giving me
what i needed they are dropping the ball
by like thinking they're doing something
with mary but they're really just like
letting jen off the hook yeah they've
got to stop like for real
yeah i want to shake them and be like
wake up this is like an historic moment
and you're [ __ ]
draw you're [ __ ] it up yeah and also
i felt like even with in beverly hills
even though they didn't like really hold
erica to account that much like they've
talked a lot about the nature of the
crimes whereas questions yeah and like
they have the la times article and they
were like okay we had the 20 million
alone this is a ponzi scheme what about
the burn victims what about
the you know boeing crash victims
and here it's like it
aside from that one conversation in the
van like
talk more about what her business is
going on yeah because like for just like
the lay people
we don't know we don't know what's going
on and we're just listening to jen it's
like she just got picked up out of
nowhere literally so that would be my
notes um you also watched sex lives of
college girls tell me what you thought
and i loved it so much did you realize
that that girl kimberly is with
charlemagne's sister i've had seen your
story okay so i already knew that and
that was already a fun thing it was like
a life-changing fact for me yeah if i
discovered it after the show i would
have been life changed but um i already
knew it who was your favorite character
honestly i think it's kimber
she really okay so i hate despised her
in the beginning but she really grew on
me but someone who i think was like
consistently funny and like the best the
whole time was bella
yeah she just had like such a great
attitude and
like she was always getting the girls
like up and at them and she's really the
reason why they're gonna become this
like unstoppable foursome uh so i
appreciated that about her because you
always need like a friend like that in
college and maybe it's because from the
beginning like you told me kimberly was
like dana so i just had a soft spot in
my heart for her do you agree that she's
dana in this in many ways she is but in
other ways she isn't but you know no
one's anyone to a t that's true
and i just thought she was so
so funny and i really liked her
character development me too um i have
recently like become obsessed with renee
uh
layton you know she's from mean girls on
broadway i found that out loud me too
and i followed her on tick tock and she
has the most incredible voice like she
all she does is sing in her car in her
house she plays a piano she's like one
of the most talented singers of all time
i hope she does like a number next
season or something he like joins you
know that show or something yeah um and
she's a lesbian in real life so it's
just like this great culmination of her
in her character and like i really can't
choose a favorite honestly yeah and i
just every time we spend more time on
one person than another like i just i
really like all of the girls and i feel
like so many of their personalities are
very real too and also the way that they
even like look
i'm sure they're actually like a little
bit older than college age girls but
like the way that they dress it's all
very ecology ecology and real and like
the parties and the and the themes like
it's it's pretty on the nose and the
social media stuff i think they like
nailed pretty nicely yeah they did i i
thought it was such a good show i'm
excited for season two i mean don't you
wish you had like a bank of seasons like
you could just watch of course because
it was just like snackable episodes
and it was a great it was just a great
show and you know what that is it's the
mindy kaling effect like she just makes
good [ __ ] like period yeah
like she gets the current like she hits
the culture yeah she's almost like a
like a night like a 12 year old stuck in
the body of like a mature woman because
she like gets it yeah i feel that way
with that other show she does um never
have i ever which i don't think you
would like no i didn't watch it they're
like in high school they're like really
young got it no it just like it was
great
it was great fun watching it honestly i
would recommend it to all the toasters i
think you guys would like it me too i
would recommend it to everyone yeah and
then yellowstone new season it's just
giving me everything and more plus
they've been pushing hard
the prequel in the comment like every
commercial and they're showing us 1883
previews with tim mcgraw faith hill sam
elliott
and that also looks really good it
actually premieres next week and i'm
excited
i'm excited to watch that too it looks
like like a lot and it's also like 1883
so you know it's a lot it better be good
yeah you know um okay well i watched
succession but i'm
forbidden from speaking about it so
that's our show that's our show plus
like to spoil it like i'm not the only
one who didn't launch last night
are you gonna watch it tonight yeah okay
um well that's our show thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
shows at the millennium morning show
where we deliver the fastest stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
it's spotify itunes stitch or public
radio i have radio box all the places
wherever we listen podcast my next
morning tell us leave a five star view
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are and if you made it to the end of
this episode thank you so much for
actually listening to us we really
appreciate it why don't you go drop an
emoji on our most recent instagram to
let us know that you made it to the end
how about the rocket ship in honor of
the time person of the year elon musk
and his never ending journey to space
yes go elon go elon
have a great day everyone we'll see you
tomorrow bye